hello everybody hello so my name is
Martin clef man I'm a researcher at the
University of Cambridge I'd like to talk
about some of the work on formal
verification that we've done recently
which always starts with the question if
you're writing a program how do you know
that the program is correct or not how
do you know that it's doing what it's
supposed to be doing and for most people
of course the answer to this is testing
so you write tests in which you think up
some examples of inputs that you want to
give to your program and you run that
input through the program and see what
comes out of the other end and check
that it is what you expected the
limitation here of course being that you
only test those inputs that you thought
of if there are any inputs that would
cause a bug that you didn't think of
they're not in your tests so people try
to extend this model for example
property based testing the idea is that
you generate a whole lot of random
inputs according to some pattern and
check whether some property always holds
of those that already broadens the scope
of the inputs that we can test taking it
a little bit further still model
checking is getting a bit of attention
the idea here being that you write an
abstract description of what your system
or your algorithm is doing and a model
checker will then try to systematically
try through all the possible
combinations of what could possibly
happen the problem here however is that
you get an exponential state explosion
and so if what you're testing is a
distributed algorithm where messages
could be delivered in any order quickly
you end up with the vast number of Rob
ability rough number of possibilities to
try through and what people have to do
in practice with model checking is to
bount the size of the model and to say
for example we will test only runs of
the system in which a maximum of 5
messages are sent and well if there's a
bug in your system that only occurs if
six messages are sent you won't find
that so formal proof is right at the
other extreme here where actually we
want to guarantee that some properties
hold in absolutely all possible
circumstances even if there's an
infinite
eight space we still want to be able to
prove that certain properties hold in
every possible configuration of a system
even if they're infinitely many so proof
is kind of hard work
I must admit so you might other wonder
whether it is at all to bother I will
try to motivate it very briefly
so for like very run-of-the-mill code
it's probably not worth bothering with
with proof because it is a fair amount
of effort and if like the code is kind
of obvious what it's doing and there's
not much I'm big UT okay fine you don't
need proof so it's most useful for
algorithms that are very subtle or
algorithms that have a very big state
space so in distributed systems this
does occur a lot or general concurrent
algorithms where you know any sort of
things could happen concurrently
different nodes might execute steps in
arbitrary orders messages might be never
delivered or delivered out of order or
duplicated or delivered ten days later
or whatever so for those kind of
algorithms formalization is super
helpful mostly actually because it helps
us as humans understand these algorithms
better and help us think through really
systematically what's going on here but
there's also another motivation for
wanting to do this kind of thing and
this is a quote from my collaborator
Dominic who said that isabell which is
the software I'll be talking about today
is the world's most complicated video
game you know we're talking about
mathematical proof here which people
don't normally associate with games but
I must say it is actually quite fun it
is really like a sort of puzzle game
where you're trying to figure out oh I
could try and combine this fact with
that fact but I'm still missing
something else from over here so maybe I
can get that from dand and I can combine
these things and then oh look it works
so I would like to give you a bit of a
taste of what this kind of proof looks
like if we're using some proof software
like Isabelle and I will as an example
use a distributed system so I wanted to
show an example that is a bit
non-trivial so that you know we can
actually talk about something that looks
a bit interesting this also means that I
won't have time to
go through the entire proof in the 40
minutes we have here but I'll try to
show you at least a few key moments so
that you get a flavor bit of a taste of
what it looks like and so we can Isabel
or Isabel flash whole is the program
we're using here it doesn't actually
have built-in support for distributed
systems it just works on standard data
structures like lists and sets and
things like that but it turns out that
we can model a distributed system very
simply using about 50 lines of code or
so and what I'm going to do is within
that model of a distributed system
formalize a simple consensus algorithm
so you might have heard of consensus
algorithm such as Paxos or raft I'll be
talking talking about a simpler one
today because paxil is a bit too big
again to talk about in this talk but it
will have the fundamental property that
we want consensus algorithms to have so
what makes a consensus algorithm correct
is in particular the agreement property
and that is if you've got two processes
in the system that are trying to reach
consensus then at some point those
processes learn or decide a value and if
that happens if any two processes have
decided decided a value then those
values must be the same that is they
agree on the value that they have
decided so the protocol or the algorithm
that we will use will look like this
I'll show you as an example here so the
example is usual consensus example of
trying to agree where to go for lunch
and so the red user at the top here
would like to go and eat tacos and the
blue user at the bottom would like to
eat falafel and the way our consensus
algorithm is going to work is we have
two types of node we have proposals
which those are the two proposals marked
here right now and we have one special
node that is called the acceptor and so
this is Paxos terminology the we only
have one accept our node and it is in
charge of making to see the decision of
where everyone's going to go for lunch
and the way it's going to make this
decision is very simple whenever a
proposer wants to go to lunch in a
particular place it sends a four
hosel message to the acceptor and the
acceptor simply sits there waiting for
proposal messages to come in and the
first time the acceptor receives a
proposed message with a particular value
in this case falafel is the first one it
receives it decides that value and then
it sends back a message to the proposer
saying yes your value was accepted
whatever proposals arrived later at the
acceptor they get told sorry and a value
has already decided so in this case here
falafel was already decided so the
proposal of tacos arrived arrived later
and so the proposal one is going to get
back a message no sorry I have already
accepted falafel and so this is a simple
consensus algorithm it works and it has
the property or this disagreement
property that at the end proposal 1 and
proposal to both have the same decided
value of falafel so let's model this so
we have here 3 communicating entities
and we have time going from left to
right and we can split this time into
time steps into discrete time steps and
we're going to say in each time step one
of the nodes does something in
particular one of the nodes handles some
kind of event and so for example in the
first time step the event is that the
red user makes a request in the second
time step the event is that the blue
user makes a request as a side-effect of
handling these events the proposals send
messages to the acceptor and those
messages arrive at some later point in
time and so at the third time step the
event here is that our message has been
received so the acceptor has received a
message from the proposer
and the fourth time step again a message
was received and in the fifth and sixth
time staff then the to accept messages
are received so what we can do here is
to model the execution of this
distributed system as just a linear
sequence of time steps and in each time
step one of the processes takes some
kind of action so this kind of model is
actually very similar to what tli + does
for example it also breaks an execution
into just a linear sequence of time
steps
and the way we're going to describe our
algorithm now is essentially as an event
handler so we can define a step function
a function that takes three arguments
and returns a pair of two arguments so
the three arguments that it takes are
firstly the process ID so which process
is executing right now secondly the
current state of that particular process
and thirdly the events that occurred for
example receiving a message and then
that function is going to return two
things it's going to return a new state
so the process moves moves from the
current state to the new State and it
returns a set of messages to send to
other nodes that may be no messages at
all or it might be several messages or
just one message and so we can use this
this kind of model here to encode the
algorithm in Ysabel so I will show you
just a little bit of introduction to
Isabelle syntax so that you can read the
examples that I'll show you in a moment
so I'm just going to compare it to
Python arbitrarily because hopefully
most people haven't seen at least a bit
of Python so you can define a function
in Isabel and in this case the identity
function that just returns the argument
that you give it in Isabel that there
are several different key words actually
in this case fun and definition which
can both be used to define functions
they have slightly different properties
but the distinction is not really
important for our purposes today
secondly you can have anonymous
functions also known as lambdas so in
Python you would write out the word
lambda in Isabel you just use the Greek
letter lambda lambda X dot X is again
the identity function that returns X and
finally if you want to call a function
or apply some argument to a function in
most programming languages you will have
the function name and then in
parenthesis the argument Isabel uses a
more ml like syntax in which you simply
have the function name space argument
and so any arguments are just separated
by spaces like this we still have
parenthesis but only for grouping not
for function invocation okay
so that's enough syntax for now let's go
back to this example so we want to write
down some code
that will implement this particular
consensus algorithm here and I'm going
to start with pseudocode just to ease us
into the situation and so we will have
separate code for the proposer or any
proposer and the acceptor and this is
written kind of like an event handler so
the proposer when the proposer receives
a user request it will send that
proposed value to the acceptor and so
those are those first two arrows that
are happening here and then later when
the proposal earns get receives a
response back from the acceptor it will
learn that decided values so that
proposal will then update its own local
state to say ah I know now what the
decided value is and we want that to to
agree with everybody else and then on
the acceptor side the acceptor doesn't
receive any user requests directly it
only receives messages over the network
from the proposers so whenever the
acceptor receives a proposal from a
proposer it needs to check its local
state if it has already decided the
value then it just sends that previously
decided value back otherwise if it has
not yet decided a value then it now
takes that opportunity to decide the
value and sends that value back and so
that's what we have here happening in
the middle on the acceptor and so I
think we should go into Isabel and show
you what this actually looks like
so here we have Isabel it's it uses a
kind of interactive IDE as you can see
here and at the beginning here is just
essentially the file name and we've
imported network which is a small
library that I've defined just for the
purposes of modeling a distributed
system if we have time I can show you
that as well otherwise all of this code
is online so you can look at it in your
own time as well so first of all we're
going to define a datatype for messages
and so this is just like a tagged Union
type like you get in many programming
languages so a message is either a
proposal message containing a value or
an accept message containing a value and
the value here is just a type variable
saying it can be of any data type
friends polymorphic and then we have
definitions of the step function for the
proposer and the step function for the
acceptor and these exactly match the
pseudocode that we had just now so let's
see for the proposer we had firstly
handling the user requests so here this
is handling the user requests this
function here the function arguments are
written using pattern matching so again
like what you get in ml or even rust you
get this kind of pattern matching of the
arguments which is quite a nice way of
writing things and the function is
written here that the first argument
here that is none is the local state the
current state of the function so I've
defined here the the local state of each
node is an option type it starts off as
none because no value has been decided
and then once the value has been decided
it goes to some X and so here we're
saying we're in the state where no value
has already been decided but we get a
user request for some value Val and this
function is going to return a pair of
two things so it's going to return first
of all the new local state the new local
state just remains none here on the
proposer
and secondly a set of messages to send
and here we're going to send a proposed
message containing that value to zero so
zero here is the recipient of the
message and I'm going to just take the
convention that the acceptor is node
number zero and proposers are nodes
number 1 2 3 etc
many nodes as we like and so here the
curly braces are to denote your set it's
a set containing one element namely the
sending of this one proposal so this is
handling a user request here and the
second line here is then handling the
response and so here we're pattern
matching on the event and here the event
is to receive a message and the message
that we're receiving is an accepted
method and so if we receive an accept
message now we will update a local state
and so our local state now goes from
none to some value and we're going to
not send any more messages so just empty
set here for the set of messages we send
so you can see here this this language
we have here in Isabel
it's an ml style functional programming
language actually Isabel kind of has a
two levels of language so you can notice
here that each line is enclosed in these
little angle brackets so everything
outside if the angle brackets is the the
outer language which is actually Isabel
which is basically a very abstract logic
language and inside the inside the
braces is whole for higher-order logic
which is kind of a functional
programming language the interesting
thing about it is that while most
programming languages are built to be
evaluated like you call a function and
then it results in some return value the
Isabel functional programming language
here is more designed to be symbolically
manipulated and so we don't just call a
function we actually take the definition
of that function and manipulate it in
ways that follows the rules of logic and
through doing that we can improve things
about it okay so that's the proposer
function on the acceptor yendo
pseudocode we said when we receive a
proposal from the proposer we look at
our local state depending on whether the
local state is decided or not we either
decide a new value or keep the existing
value and so we have exactly the same
here on the acceptor acceptor in some
existing state state and it receives a
proposal a proposal from the sender some
sender
and what we're going to do here is match
on pattern match on that case on the
state if the state is none that means
there's no decided value so far so now
we're going to decide a value so the new
local state is some value and we're
going to respond to the sender by
sending back an except message on the
other hand if the acceptor has already
decided a value previously that is the
state is some V then the state will
remain some V we're never going to
change the decided value once it's been
decided but we still send back a message
to the proposer saying hey actually I've
decided this other value already and
this last line here is just the
wild-card which covers all of the other
cases and so I have that both in the
proposer and in the acceptor function
and so here I'm saying the proposer
insert is in some state for every other
event that might be received we remain
in the same state and we don't send any
messages and so this is just an OAuth
saying we're going to ignore anything
else that might happen so this is enough
to define the algorithm here the only
last thing I need to do is define the
step function here takes this first
argument the process ID and so I'm going
to say if the process is zero then the
code we're running is the acceptor which
I said just now is zeros the acceptor
any other number is going to be a
proposer and so this is now enough to
define the algorithm so what we want to
do now is prove some interesting things
about it so what we want to prove is the
agreement property and I will just again
introduce just a little bit of
mathematical notation in case you've not
seen it before or have forgotten since
your undergraduate degree so logical
implication is this double arrow the
arrow pointing from left to right and
what this says is that if the stuff on
the left-hand side of the arrow is true
then the thing on the right-hand side
must also be true and so on the
left-hand side we can have assumptions
the little hats thing means and so if
the statement p1 is true and the
statement p2 is true and all of these
statements up to PN are true if they are
all true then we can conclude that the
statement Q
is also true sometimes this is written
as repeated arrows so you can write the
write this equivalently date they mean
exactly the same okay and what we want
to prove is this agreement property here
that I showed you earlier
so let's formalize that let's state this
property a bit more carefully so I'm
going to say sorry the text is a little
bit small assuming that's the variable
state corresponds to the state of all of
the processes after we have executed
this consensus algorithm in particular
after we've executed any number of steps
of their consensus algorithm so it might
be not no steps have been executed or
might be that one hundred million steps
have been executed we're not going to
take any upper boundary here on how long
the algorithm will run for and we're
also going to assume that the state of
process 1 is some value 1 and the state
of process 2 is some value 2 and so
assuming those 3 things what we want to
prove is that value 1 must equal to
value 2 so this is just saying any two
processes that have decided must have
decided the same value now let's write
this in isabelle so we are here and and
we're going to we want to write a
theorem i can give a name to that
theorem and just going to call it
agreement for now and i'm going to write
these three assumptions that correspond
exactly to what we had just here so
first of all we need to somehow say that
this is the execution of our consensus
algorithm and for that i have predefined
this little function called execute
which is it's defined in a separate file
here where i can show you that later and
we're going to say we execute the
algorithm where the step function is
consensus that so that's the just a
function that i defined up here and
furthermore we need to give this the
initial state and the initial state is
going to be a function from process ID
to the state of that particular process
and I want all functions to
all processes to start off in
the state none because it's option type
and we want everyone to start off in a
state none so we can just write a
function here that takes some process ID
and always returns none and so this will
be the states of all of the processes
this is just saying all of the processes
are in the state none so the third
argument that I need to give here is the
set of processes that exist in the
system but actually I don't need to
limit which processes I exists I'm just
going to give it the universal set of
all possible processes and then we have
three more variables which is the events
the messages and the states and so this
what this here is saying is that this
event here is a list of events that
occurred so a list of messages that were
delivered or users that made requests
and and so this is a valid sequence of
events in which the set of messages that
were sent is this variable messages and
the final states of all of the processes
is this variable States here and this is
an execution of the algorithm with these
three parameters so with the consensus
step with the initial state and the set
of processes and so under this
assumption we can now say what the state
of some process should be so the state
of process one should be some value one
yes and similarly the state of process
two should be some value two and under
these assumptions we want to show that
value one equals value two okay so this
is just a nice statement of the thing we
want to prove what I'm going to write
here now for now is sorry and so sorry
is the isabelle key word which just says
believe me this is true I'm not going to
prove it
now of course you might be wrong and you
might assert that something is true if
it is not indeed true but sorry is
extremely useful while you're working on
a proof because you can't prove
everything at the same time you have to
start with some assumptions and those
assumptions you can just
out with furry for now and then come
back to them later and so the idea is
you start with sorry at the top level
and then gradually get rid of the
sorry's all of the stories in the
program and then add in the proof at the
end once you've got rid of all of the
sorry's then the computer has checked
this proof and has verified that it is
indeed true so how do we do the proof
for this now now this is kind of
interesting because it seems sort of
obvious like if you look at the
description of the algorithm it seems
kind of obvious that any two nodes will
end up deciding the same value you know
it's just kind of looking at it but here
for Isabelle in order to prove something
formally just like saying that it's
obvious it's not really good enough so
we have to break it down step by step
how does each step of the execution lead
to the fact that everybody ends up in
agreement and the steps of the execution
can be a user made a request or and a
proposed message was received or an
accept message was received and so what
is quite a common technique for proving
these kind of things is to first prove
some invariants so we're going to prove
some simpler facts which we think are
going to be true at every step of the
execution and then hopefully from those
invariants we can then deduce this
agreement property that we want to show
him and so coming up with the invariance
is kind of the most creative part of the
proof so this is something that
computers are pretty bad at and this is
why a tool like Isabel is is like an
interactive proof assistant it doesn't
try to fully automatically run the proof
by itself because that's unfortunately
undecidable just like the halting
problem but instead what we do is we
have this kind of neat interaction
between the human who kind of puts in
some hypotheses and then help the
computer helps check whether those
things are actually true and so I'm
going to assert that there are two
invariants which we can use in order to
prove the agreement property and this is
the first one here
so I'm going to clay mm-hmm I'm going to
claim for any proposal P if the state of
P is some vowel then there must exist
some process that has sent an accept
message to P with that value well how
does this make sense yes I kind of think
so because well if we think the only way
that a proposer can end up in the state
of having decided some value is by
having received an accept message that
is if you look at here the definition of
the function the proposer this is the
only place where it sets its states to
be some value and it's in response to an
accept message so okay it looks
plausible second invariant if they exist
if somebody in their system has sent an
accept vestige then the acceptor must be
in the state some value well
extending an accept message the only
note that sends accept messages is the
acceptor and it sends it here on these
two lines and here when it sends the
accept message for Val it is in the
state some Val and if it sends the
accept message with value V it is in the
state some V so this invariant also
looks plausible that whenever there's in
such an accept message then the acceptor
must be in that state but it's not
immediately so it's not immediately
obvious that those two invariants are
true and it's also not immediately
obvious that they are sufficient in
order to prove the agreement property
and so this is where something like
Isabel will be handy so in order to
write down these invariants we have to
write them a bit more formally as a
mathematical statement and for this a
bit of more notation you might have seen
this the upside down letter aid means
for all and so this is saying here for
all possible values of the variable X
the statement P of X is true and
similarly there exists so this up this
inverted letter e here is the exists
operator and we're saying we can find
some value X that maybe might might be
more than one value but there's at least
one value X for which the statement P of
X is true and so using these these
quantifiers we can now write down these
two invariants more formally
and so I am going to actually copy them
from a separate file to save a bit of
time here so I'll put them in here so
our two invariants first of all the
invariant one so this is just restating
it here in words I'm saying for any
proposed RP okay so pre or here I'm
calling it proc it's a proposer if it's
ID is not 0 because 0 is the acceptor so
any process ID that is not 0 must be a
proposer
that's any proposal P if the state of P
is some valve that's we have here
remember States is a function from
process IDs to state and so here this is
just saying States given the argument
proc and that function returns some
value here we have the arrow so that's
the implication
that's this then here in the invariant
so if these two things are true if the
process is a proposer and if the state
of that process is some vowel then the
right-hand side of the arrow is true and
here the right hand side is the arrow
says they exist some sender process that
sent an accept messages okok is the
recipient of the send message this is
the message that was sent and this is
the sender in this case we don't even
care who sent the accept message we just
say there exists some process that sent
it and this we're saying here it exists
in the set of messages and we're saying
this statement is true for all processes
and all values and this so this
definition here you can think of as a
function that takes two arguments which
is the set of messages and the set and
the map of states it is invariant one
invariant to here if a message
except Val has been sent that is this
bit here so on the left hand side of the
implication if some some accept value
here some accept value message exists
where there's some sender and some
recipients we don't care who the sender
and recipients are if this message
exists if that message was sent then the
state of the acceptor must be some value
so remember zero is the acceptor so the
state of process zero must be some value
so I'm not
interested in figuring out are these two
invariants actually sufficient to prove
this agreement property and so for that
I'm going to add here and another lemma
lemma is just like a theorem except it's
like an intermediate result I'm going to
copy this assumption here and I'm going
to assert that in any X in any valid
execution of our algorithm invariant one
holds and invariant two holds and I'm
going to use sorry again just to say
like okay let's see first of all if
those two invariants are sufficient in
order to prove this so I'm going to try
and get rid of this sorry down here and
if it's sufficient then we can actually
check if the two invariants are also
true so here let's try and prove this
agreement theorem now and now I'm going
to go into Isabel's proof mode and so
when you want to make a proof just like
a mathematical proof on pen and paper
often you need to make in steps of
reasoning so you say okay these are
assumptions what can we deduce from
these assumptions I'm going to say well
from this assumption here that the state
of process is value one we should be
able to deduce that somebody sent an
accept message with value one and from
that by invariant two we should be able
to deduce that the accept or must be
in-state some value on so let's see if
that is true so let's say the state of
the acceptor is some value one and see
if we can deduce this from the
assumptions we have here and so I'm
going to now invoke sledgehammer so
sledgehammer is an amazing command built
into here into Isabel which tries to
find the proof automatically and
sometimes it succeeds and sometimes it
doesn't normally this should work but
here this is the great thing with live
demos
okay am I missing something do a new -
what what use the use dilemma here it
should be able to find this lemma
automatically ok so I'll copy it from
the other file I might have just made a
typo somewhere so here's our invariants
lemma oh there we go okay I must have
type of it somehow
so here we go it's founder proof and
here's the proof that is found so I can
click this down here and it's just going
to put it in the file for me and let me
explain briefly what is going on here so
Metis is one of several built in proof
methods in Isabelle Isabelle comes with
a whole suite of different proof
algorithms and different proof
algorithms are good at solving different
proof problems and so just there Metis
is one of those and the arguments we
give to Metis here are all of the facts
that this proof algorithm should use and
so using assumptions 1 and assumptions 2
that is these two assumptions and using
the definitions of the two invariants
and using the invariants lemma that we
just defined here so using all of those
facts it has been able to successfully
prove that the state of the of the
acceptor is indeed some value so this is
really cool so at this point here we're
sure because the computers check this
proof we can't have made a mistake in
this step of the reasoning so now we've
done this for some value 1 but using the
third assumption here we should be able
to make a similar conclusion for value 2
so let's say moreover we also have the
States or state of the acceptor must be
some value 2 I'm going to sledgehammer
this again and again we found the proof
cool ok and the proof is probably going
to look very similar to the last roof
because it's essentially the same
argument is just using assumptions 1 and
3 whereas previously we used some
one and two by the way you see this like
this little flashing briefly flashes up
in purple that's the time that Isabelle
is taking to check that proof and once
the purple has gone away that means the
proof is correctly checked and so it's
giving this this really nice interactive
feedback okay now we have to the state
of they accept all must be value 1 and
the state of the acceptor must be value
to the only way how this works now is
for value 1 and value 2 to be the same
so ultimately we must be able to show
from this that value 1 equals value 2
let's see what Isabelle thinks I thinks
it's true and using just indicate this
case we're using a different proof
method we're using simp which is
simplification so that's just doing
syntactic manipulations on the
statements and the proof is done so I
can write QED quod erat demonstrandum
and we have proved the theorem under
this assumption of course we remember we
still got the story here but we're
making progress we have showed that
these two invariants are indeed
sufficient to prove this agreement
property I can show you like if I for
example delete the invariant 2 here then
and as proof no longer works it's just
sitting there trying to prove this step
but not succeeding because it turns out
that just in variant 1 by itself is not
strong enough we do indeed need both of
the invariance okay so let's put it back
in and now proof checks again though
this is nice not a few little details
about Isabelle so you can see it's a
it's a functional programming language
and we can do these manipulations on
terms it also it's like type inferred
uses same kind of type inference as ml
and oh camel and and we have this
sledgehammer and a bit of proof
automation which helps us write the
steps of the proof so what would be
interesting now is to look at how we
actually prove these invariants and the
way this works I will illustrate by a
little picture and so here remember we
have here in in our definition of
execute we have the sequence of events
that occur
and each event can be either a user
proposing or user requesting a value or
a message being received from the
network or maybe a time out or something
like that and so those are the things
that can occur and each process will
handle one event at a time process can
handle events in any order so it's not
round-robin or anything it's just like
arbitrary interleaving and all of the
processes start off in the initial state
and for each event that event and the
current state get fed into the step
function to produce the new state and so
like this we can kind of iterate over
this list of events and processes that
handle each event and deduce from that
the states and so what we're saying here
now is assume that our invariants hold
in this block of states here on the
right hand side assume that is the case
then we can append one more event to the
end and that event will be executed by
one of the processes and that one
process will update its local State for
all the other processes the state will
remain remain the same and what we're
saying now is that then the invariants
are still true in States prime on the
right hand side and this if you remember
some maths from college looks very much
like induction and this is indeed an
induction proof and so what we need to
prove is firstly some statement holds
for the empty list and moreover we can
prove that some statement holds for some
if if some statement holds for some list
excess then we can append some value X
to the list XS and the statement still
holds and this is exactly what we want
for these invariants and so for the
proof here we break down the proof into
two steps the base case where we showed
that some that the invariants hold for
the empty list of events where nothing
has happened I H holds in the initial
State and then secondly we show that
given some valid state we can then apply
one more event at the end of the list
and that is the inductive step and from
these we can prove that the statement
holds for all lists and amazingly look
here we have to do
only two sub proofs we only have to
prove the base case and the inductive
step but from these two things we can
deduce that this statement is true for
all lists XS regardless have a lot of
how long they are so we've proved a
statement about an infinite state space
but we've only had to do a finite amount
of work in order to do this proof so
I'll show you very briefly because I
have one more minute just how the start
of an induction proof looks like in
Isabel and so here I want to prove this
lemma here at the invariance and I say
I'm going to use the assumptions and I'm
going to do a proof by induction I'm
going to do a induction over one of the
variables so the variable here is going
to be the list event and we have to say
messages and states are arbitrary that
means they can vary at each step of the
induction and finally we need to define
the rule that we're using so I'm doing
induction on lists and whether so the
inductive step is going to be appending
one item to the end of the list that's
what this this rule here says so I have
to write that one line by hand but now
here there's some cogeneration I can use
so here we go look now we've got
immediately the base case and the
inductive step as 2 sub-goals here and
I've got sorry for each of those and so
now I can for example try and prove the
base case so the base case is basically
just that this statement here that the
two invariants hold for the empty list
of events ie in the initial state so
let's see if sledgehammer can do that
there we go
profound give it a moment there we go
so here profound we're using again we're
using a different proof method this time
the proof algorithm is called fast force
and here these are the various facts and
lemmas that were using in the proof of
this but here we've proved the base case
of the induction already so next is now
to do the step of the induction but I'm
afraid I'm out of time for that so I
will not be able
show you that today I would I'm thinking
actually maybe I'll do like a video
recording of this because if if I had
another hour two hours I would be able
to run through the entire proof and and
it's actually quite interesting
the remarkable thing here is that
actually this induct
DZ these invariants are the main
creative step in the proof so actually
by the time I've got here now the rest
of the proof is actually pretty
mechanical it's another about 200 lines
or so of code to write but a lot of
those codes come from the automation so
I can just keep doing sledgehammer
sledgehammer and all of these simple
steps of the proof sledgehammer can do
automatically and there's actually not
too much more creative thinking required
so from this point actually it's fairly
doable so that's about as much as I have
time to talk about today I'm afraid if
you're interested in the full proof you
can find it here I just put it on a gist
on github and I don't have time for
questions but I'll be here in the lunch
break so feel free to come up to me
thank you so much for coming
[Applause]